what freaked me out is that outside of
the mathematics of
making a sign curve the actual
result of a computer back then was
pretty stupid
there was no difference between the real
world and the virtual world
[Music]
earl hall thank you so much for being on
my show how are you
good and how about you i am doing just
fine where are you talking to you right
now
where are you talking from right now i
am in the beautiful city of las vegas
nevada
las vegas nevada what are you doing in
las vegas nevada
i'm building an artificial intelligence
company we've been at it for almost 10
years right now we pick up data
out of slot machines from about 50
countries right now
and our goal with that data is
to bring forward algorithms for
anti-money laundering
to cure responsible gaming and with
covid we're doing a lot of
things in the cashless world so we've
been at this for a long while
we're not really a startup so earl this
is a fascinating industry and it's
particularly fascinating to me because i
know nothing about it so aside from the
fact that i enjoy
the occasional trip with friends and i
myself are more of a
more of a poker guy but but i but but
first i have to go back a little bit and
you have a long history with technology
not just access ai
but all the way i'd love to go back to
your growing up and you just mentioned
you had a pretty fascinating take on on
your interaction with computers
uh talk to me a little bit about that
well i grew up in a very small
place it's a little tiny island right
out in the north atlantic in canada
called newfoundland
or newfoundland as we call it at home
light comes from away
from the musical yes but exactly that
not far from where i was born actually
and the issue was one i was very blessed
that even though we were in a small
place
a relatively modest place we did have
computers in school back in the 19
early 1980s wow but what freaked me out
is that outside of the mathematics of
making a sine curve the actual
result of a computer back then was
pretty stupid
there was no difference between the real
world and the virtual world
and that's really what i didn't like as
i graduated through computers went into
the army
and then just to talk about the army
then i saw the
intelligence that we were using back
then to keep a
tank's muzzle pointed towards the target
and that's where my heart started to
beat this if you can keep
the muzzle straight while the vehicle is
moving
then i started looking at how artillery
was projecting
getting into precision and then my heart
started to beat for artificial
intelligence
wow so then i said it's okay wait he
said we can
yeah already back then you were thinking
about official intelligence
i don't wanna we've come up with all
these buzzwords now that
are okay but the thing is is for me it's
predictability
if you look at the human psyche we have
two things that keep us out of the
present moment
we have fear of reproducing the past
sure or regret from the past or we have
things from the past
giving us fear that are predicting
negative things of the future and that's
really the way the animal brain
works that's the way we get all polluted
with cortisol and things inside of our
brain
so for me back then i didn't have the
word artificial intelligence
until really the movie matrix that i
worked on with
my team in special effects for movies
but for me the word was predictability
how are they predicting keeping that
straight with everything that's going on
and that's when mathematics really
started to make my heart beat
so mathematics make your heart beat give
me a couple sentences about mit matrix
what
what's that all about well
i was working in a company i was
building a company that was doing
some very advanced uh scanning of human
bodies to be able to move them
into the virtual world and then morph
them
on to wire frames so we could do
animation
and when i actually understood what the
what the movie the matrix was trying to
project as
an artificial intelligence world saying
warning red flag i went oh my god okay
good
now i get it and at the same time i was
recruited to teach
at the master's degree level in
management of information
so i'll be honest now that it's a long
time ago i used to use my
students as guinea pigs to do all kinds
of papers on things that were
edge back then wow to try to get
food into my brain to understand where
the world was going
predictability so how do you end up in
the gaming industry you're now talking
to me from las vegas and
and i'd love to in a second dive into
what is the gaming industry
what is anti-money laundering and why
and what is the role of ai within the
gaming industry but before that
how do you make that transition um i was
in a totally different world
i was actually in a totally different
part of the world
and i got approached by one of the large
accounting firms that a
company in the gaming space was going
bankrupt because of the fact that they
had a lot of patents a lot of potential
but they ran out of cash and they needed
they needed to be restructured
so i was parachuted in to restructure
that and i'll be honest i'd never been
in a casino in my entire life
wow up to that point of course
kicked up the company fixed it it ended
up getting sold and
towards the end before it got sold i got
asked by
a very prestigious shareholder that's
one of my mentors
please come help me build this company
that i have here
and when i saw what he was doing i was
completely in trouble because it was the
intersection of all of my dreams
big data i wouldn't be able to do it
without blockchain
and it was 100 taking me in the
direction where i wanted to go of
building an app store to be able to
welcome any app in the planet
onto the big data and all of that was
fueling my vision to get towards ai so
my mentor actually rolled out a red
carpet for me to
live my tech dream okay so so you're
you're now finding yourself in las vegas
in the gaming space give me a little bit
of context because i know very little
about the gaming
space let alone las vegas and i'm sure
that a lot of my friends also
while we may enjoy it from time to time
we're not we don't really understand
this
this you know ecosystem of what's
happening there so give me a little bit
of background
well we're kind of a stranger to the
entire industry because the industry was
brought up
on slot machines and table games
and data was largely localized inside of
all of the casinos
back in the old days was because of
trust issues and
today it's largely because of technology
issues so
we showed up out of the blue with a
vision that was
very much years ahead of everybody else
by saying
we've got to get all of the data out and
get it into the cloud
so that we can manage performance we can
manage
kyc we can manage regulatory issues
but at the same time our job is to bring
in things that can cure and advance the
industry
so what does that mean current advanced
so for cured of what and what does it
mean to advance
the gaming industry well there are a lot
of places around the world that still
have legitimacy issues with gaming where
there's two things either it's uh it's
either it's a safe haven for crime
or it's a potential area where addiction
can
infiltrate in so most people don't
see that gaming can bring in those
things but i can tell you i travel
almost 100 countries uh for this for
this
project i'm building and you see a lot
of crazy stuff around the world
a lot hundred countries yep and you see
a lot of crazy stuff
yep oh well over a hundred but i round
it down to a hundred
so the thing is is that what's driving
our passion is that we can actually
bring in a little bit of light
into some dark spaces like when you hook
in our system into a jurisdiction into a
place into a casino
the moneyline is in a lot of trouble
because we trace every single click
every single movement every single
change
and our algorithms are monitoring
anything that's outside
of the normal so if somebody is in there
trying to launder money we picked them
up in a heartbeat
wow so what have you seen happen around
the world
as you're putting in as you're putting
in these you know these technologies
give me a little bit of the insight over
there
well one of the things i guess is like
any consumer based industry like you
know if you read any of the uh the stuff
that walmart's been putting out over the
years that
the greatest threat to theft in
a uh in a walmart is usually employees
well it goes without saying that one of
the greatest threats inside of the
casino industry
is collusion between an employee and an
outside force sure like i've seen i've
seen in guatemala unfortunately that
organized crime actually were
threatening
with bodily harm employees inside of a
casino
that if they weren't helping them rig
the cards in the back or a game
that members of their family would be
hurt or even worse
wow so this is a little bit different
also from the you know
the classic movie 21 that that we're all
familiar with
where it's you know genius
mathematicians counting cards
there you know it sounds like the the
whole the the
the money laundering industry within
gaming industry is a little bit more
complicated than that
it's a lot more complicated and it's
very invisible because of the fact that
it's
it's getting very sophisticated
sure which means that if you have a
server you have an information
management system that's in one casino
and there's a different one and another
one well the money launderers and the
card counters on the blackjack side
they will just dabble in different
places
so that they're so far under the radar
of what any algorithm inside of a
one lone silo place could offer
in terms of uh intelligence
richness big data micro data
sets uh you'll never find them but when
you're running
big data algorithms like the algorithms
we have
we start by running them over the whole
planet so they're running over 50
countries
wow then we bring them down into
regional
then we bring them down into micro
algorithms so as i'm sure you know
there's a lot of there's a big
difference between big data and micro
data
we do both because you you have to catch
them wherever they're trying to
cheat the data right and so so walk me
through the process of of catching
somebody who's trying to cheat the data
so oh that's not our job i stay away
from that
no no not the physical because they
would come after me and bury me all we
do
is we get a flag transaction
that says this transaction looks
suspecting
and the email goes off to the
appropriate person
and what could be a trigger of that
though so could that be
that they're winning an exp and an
unexpected amount of money
oh they don't want to win they don't
want to win what they want to do is
cash in money play a little bit so that
the
unclean money goes into a legitimate
machine
right you play a little bit and then you
take it back out
so that it becomes a legitimate amount
of money right because it's been cashed
into that environment
then you might see in sophisticated
places where they'll move to one machine
to another
to bring down the actual amount that
they're going to cash out
there's several different models i'd
like to call it
but it's all the same thing it's trying
to move money out of a legitimate source
into a legitimate system wow so
now that access is a bit have been
around for about 10 years
and you're operating in in 50 countries
how big is the problem today how big
is cheating in casinos today
i'm not going to say it's alarming
because of the fact that
a lot of the countries that were behind
in technology are
now leaping forward in technology
like if you look at mexico which was
really a place that needed to be cleaned
up very bad
about 15 years ago when you look at it
today it's using cashless technology
it's using all kinds of algorithms it's
really taking leaps
forward the problem is not what i'd like
to say a 9-1-1 in the language we use
here in the united states
but it's a serious problem that has to
be dealt with on a global
level that's the reason why i'm a big
fan of a cashless society because if
if you if you can't move dirty money
into a clean space
well you can only be inside of a clean
environment and i know that you're also
pretty involved with blockchain in
general so i assume that
that the passion for that was it comes
from comes from a similar understanding
right
well it's because a i is dependent on
the
integrity of the data is using if you
can manipulate the data
if you can skew the data if you can
delete the data
your algorithm is actually corrupt
right without you knowing it 100 whereas
if you're using any form of blockchain
whether it be
centralized or decentralized blockchain
i really don't care
you're saying that the security and the
integrity of the data is the underlying
food that you're feeding the algorithms
definitely
that's why ai without blockchain for me
is kind of yeah
whatever when you started out accessing
and you're trying to build these models
that
are are looking at the gaming industry
and and i can only imagine because
you're going because you know there's so
many different types of machines so many
different
types of behaviors that could happen um
and and
it's it's really a fascinating realm
from a psychological aspect
but do you have to onboard people that
are specialized in gaming
or they're simply great engineers and
you're t and and you're explaining to
them how the gaming industry works
because you yourself
didn't really you don't really you're
not it doesn't sound like you're a
really gamer by heart right
no i'm not and i i'll say that
i've been blessed at access because when
i look at my whole team
around the world and the different
offices we have
i'm surrounded by geniuses whether they
like gaming or not
is no bearing on what we do because the
second
blessing of any leader and i'm going to
say this for the startups not for the
large
mega companies on on the dow or whatever
but if you're smart enough as a leader
you'll let your clients teach you
my first sentence that i always give to
my clients is hey
i don't know your business and i'll be
honest i'll probably never know it as
good as you do
so if you teach me what you need to
teach me so that i can
protect you and give you tools to go
bigger better faster
i said we'll have a great marriage
together so
we do have people on our team that know
gaming but that's not the heart of who
we are
who we are is listening to our clients
and following them on their path what
does a casino look like
in five ten years given that
we go back to in person entertainment
and all that
you've just hit it on the nose online
gaming
is becoming the staple
for somebody who wants to spin a virtual
slot machine for 10 minutes and
win lose or whatever doesn't matter but
at the end of the day
a casino is really a gathering point for
entertainment
even in the smallest little casinos that
i've been in in africa
or in the philippines or anywhere else
there's always an intersection between
food
between social between playing that 20
40 60 80 dollars that you have in your
pocket
right and i'll always
believe that bricks and mortar are going
to be around forever
because as covid has shown us everybody
ran home in march goes
yes work from home then the personality
type started to emerge between
may june july and we realized some
people need to be in a social
environment all the time some people
don't want to be in the social
environment
anytime but the majority the 60 percent
that are
living on the top of the bell curve they
need to be in a social environment some
of the time
all the time earl this is all
fascinating before we leave a
last question because we talked about
just briefly before
talk to me a little bit about a
neuroscience ai something that you're
particularly excited or scared about
give me give me you know your your one
or two minute a brief about
your understanding of neuroscience and
where you're in it
well i'm dug in deep to the relation
between the pituitary gland and the
pineal gland
why because the pituitary gland is
really the
seat of the animal brain and the
pineal gland is really the seat of the
human brain
and they're constantly in conflict
between fight and flight
and trying to find that zen moment where
you're inspired
to really be who you are right
and the more that i looked at technology
over the last 20 years i realized
that the only way to understand
artificial intelligence
or enhanced intelligence is to
understand the difference between the
lower and the higher brain
sure so i started to dig in and i
dug in for personal reasons i i lived a
very traumatic
event in my personal life with my son
and
i sat i i set out on a
journey to fix what i broke with my son
and that just led me in a direction that
was so beautiful because
today when i look forward i see the
human
i see information technology i see
the intersection and i'm putting back on
my warriors suit to make sure that i'm
on the right side of this fight
i just love it earl this was so
insightful and so
inspiring thank you for taking the time
to do this before we leave i have to ask
you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself
inspiring others to be themselves
inspiring others to be themselves i
think it's the hardest thing a human has
to figure out it's to learn how to be
and trust themselves so
that's really big part of my job
sticking the mirror in
my team's faces and making them realize
how
absolutely beautiful they really are
earl
thank you very very much this is just
wonderful continue doing good for the
world
and and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you very much for the invite i
absolutely love what you're doing
congratulations
thank you bye-bye take care